I had to pull the video we have to oh
yeah we gotta watch this we gotta play
it we have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers and The Growers saying
why are you shipping these uh
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the cops down here
I just love that she's like wait a
second we need them to pick the crops is
like the permanent perennial Democrat
talking point it goes all the way back
to the founding of the Democrat Party we
need them to pick the crops it's always
been the issue for Democrats that's true
it's just changed it's just remarkable
to me that she's basically saying right
now to the press and everyone else a
group of farmers said we are employing
people illegally who entered the country
illegally please don't take these people
away from us and there's just so much
here where it's like well Nancy as an
officer of of the government maybe you
could inform law enforcement that crimes
are being committed and they're
requesting of you to assist them in the
crimes being committed and your only
response to be like they like it that
that's just the the people who are
coming and you earlier in the show you
said criminal and criminal migrants
Criminal Minds because we took our laws
right and that's that's like you know I
hear a lot from the left they're like no
one's illegal and I'm like that's a good
point a person isn't illegal but they
can't be criminals and if you break the
law and you're here you're a criminal
migrant that makes sense so she's
actually here arguing for the law to be
broken
it's it's it's it's it's
I don't know chaos what was the word we
were talking about um when the cities
are Decay Decay degradation it doesn't
mean you're a bad person I live in a
completely cubanate like it's a Cuban
neighborhood right Tampa is the number
one buy by city by city population the
number one Landing place for Cuban
migrants and I like I assume most of
them were not here legally right they
came from Cuba there was a lot of them
and they they came illegally those
people are the best patriots man those
people are awesome
Tam's an amazing Community if you ever
go to Ybor City in Tampa get a
hand-rolled cigar get a proper Cuban
coffee it looks like it looks like
Havana should should look without
without the communism I don't I don't
think people should be illegal entering
the country but I will say I have
infinitely more respect for illegal
immigrants fleeing communism and even
the the migrant from Honduras was like I
want Buffalo Wild Wings Coming to
America I have more respect for them
than the leftists who are like America
is evil and racist yes now I'm not happy
that they break the law to come here
because they want Buffalo Wild Wings as
for the people fleeing communism fleeing
here and then applying for Asylum I get
and hopefully they get it because
communism sucks but you have too many
people in this country who just outright
hate it despite the fact that everyone's
fleeing to get here
I mean I call them criminal migrants for
that exact reason I'm not trying to say
that that anyone should break our laws
to come here you weren't invited and and
by the way this is this is Democrat law
this was passed and ratified by Joe
Biden of all people in the in the Senate
uh where if you are if you cross our
border illegally it is your uh dude it
is your duty to turn yourself in
immediately to border patrol and and and
then to essentially like surrender
yourself right to authorities that that
is the law of the land so it is a legal
act it is a felony it is a federal
felony to cross our border illegally and
that is the that is the black law of the
land so so the Joe Biden is breaking the
law this is a law of course that he
ratified because you you re-up this and
then you you re-ratify this is the
Immigration Act Immigration Act of like
1964 1963 I can't remember but anyway I
again I just it's it's it's a criminal
act that's why we call them a criminal
you're a criminal migrant 1965.
immigration and nationality Act of 1965.
Yep this it's reminiscent of the slave
trade the African slave trade people are
coming over though then it was legal
what they were doing highly amoral You
could argue but they were shipping
humans over in Chains and then putting
them on the plantation to work for low
wages these people are coming across
illegally whether they're being
trafficked across like the slaves were
of the African slave trade or if they're
coming over their own will and then
they're working for cheap labor like
it's very similar are they gonna then I
don't want to be cynical about it man
but I'm like in 200 years or their
ancestors going to be asking for
reparations because they were poor they
came from poverty like it it
I don't know man but there it's not
they're not in Bound and chains that's
the difference is they're here because
it's better than where they were which
is a lot of them were also working
illegally a lot of them are being taken
advantage of a lot of multinational
corporations use them and depend on them
to get rich while of course not
following the regulations not following
the rules not even paying them minimum
wage in many instances so who's the real
winner here a lot of the Big Top
multinational corporations as of course
wages go down because there's an influx
of workers housing goes up as of course
there's less housing and who loses the
Blue Collar the average American the
person who is here who came here without
the right paperwork who of course is
going to be a slave of the multinational
corporations taking advantage I think
this uh the statement from Pelosi should
be probable cause probable cause enough
to check the check the documentation of
her Plantation yes or absolutely
Plantation Pelosi that's why we call our
Plantation and also if the people that
want like reparations or are upset about
the African-American slave trade in the
history and everything that's going on
right now with racism you got to turn
your focus on the illegal immigration
racket in the United States because
those are the modern day slaves if you
want to fix the past to start with the
present there's still slavery right now
in in Libya because of the U.S overthrow
over that government there which Hillary
Clinton orchestrated celebrated and now
Africans who are trying to go to the
Middle East are literally being put as
and sold as slaves inside of Libya right
now as we're speaking so like are you
still a slave if your chains are
invisible no there's real chains in
Libya okay so Libya There's real chains
I would argue that a lot of the people
that are coming across the border based
on our border visit down to Yuma Arizona
and we went and spent two days in Yuma
Arizona in the Yuma sector and we talked
with the sheriff there and he drove us
around he got we got in our little truck
we drove along the border we drove along
Trump's wall it was glorious and then it
just ends right it just ends part of it
is because it ends because of an Indian
reservation and they're working with the
tribe to get it built on there part of
it ends because Joe Biden just letting
the wall rust in the middle of the
desert the uh the sheriff drives us uh
to the middle of uh where they cross and
he says that's the rape tree
go over to the rape tree that's how the
women pay their toll because they don't
have any money to get in America
so in case you're wondering how this
works go over there and we go over there
there's like there's like ripped
clothing there's like panties there's
like all this horrible stuff there's
little children's toys I like like every
little stuffed animals it's sickening it
is a lot of it is and it is the largest
human slave trade I would argue because
these people that are coming here as
indentured to Luke's Point indentured
like a servants right to work for
corporations and again they get shipped
off to Iowa County Iowa hog Factory
right they already have like their
papers right that's where they go they
work for the coyotes yo it is the
world's largest human smuggling
operation or slave trade depending on if
you think the teams are invisible the
coyotes tell some of these people not
every single one works this way they'll
say it's you know two or three thousand
dollars to get uh to get your passage
paid for and if you don't have it you'll
work to pay us pay it off so these
people are coming in they're coming
they're coming indebted to these human
traffickers then they have to work and
send money back I remember I once went
to a restaurant and uh I'll keep the the
the uh the details more vague but people
who work there were all clearly migrants
and someone got really mad the tip
wasn't big enough and it was because we
didn't have a server we come into a
restaurant with no server we order up at
the counter we sit down and then
afterwards they demanded a tip and I'm
like if we had a waiter like I usually
tip really well they started yelling at
us and so what what I was told from
someone is that the people who come here
they're indentured servants they get
paid quote unquote but they have this
extra legal system where back home
there's there's rules and laws that
apply to them here in America that don't
apply in America but it's like we paid
five grand to move it to America you're
going to work for our company that our
people own we're gonna pay you and then
you're gonna send the money back to us
or else so if they they need to make a
certain amount of money every week to
send it back home to pay off the debt to
get them to move to America so they get
really mad when you're not giving them
more money than they do the or else part
makes them slaves for sure like if they
are afraid made for their families lives
or afraid they're going to get hunted
down if they don't if they don't work
then they're in a state of slavery yeah
isn't the number one source of income in
Mexico remittances from the United
States did I read that somewhere wow is
that true I believe that how does that
how does that work uh so it's money
coming from the United States for people
who are sending it back to Mexico so
that's the number one source of income
or a very high level source of income I
would like to have an article to check
that but we've we've read it on the show
before
it's got to be wire transfers and stuff
that do they track it how's that there's
electric seven dollar bills cash too
yeah I love how Western Union Bitcoin
all of it I love how these like Urban
Millennial liberal types have started
colonizing Mexico City
that's true I mean you saw the story
they're like all moving down there and
they're like I just love these tacos the
rent is so cheap and the locals are just
like this is terrible you don't speak
our language and you're ruining our
favorite spots yeah that story was
something else yeah a plague dude a lot
of American cities
the woke the woke liberals yeah yeah I
mean like try to go try to go have like
a nice time in LA or in Detroit or into
Chicago you're from Chicago yeah and
right like talk about another ghost town
like Michigan Avenue I mean I haven't
been there stores are closed down in
Michigan oh man it's like well I mean
there's only so many cars you can drive
into the storefront right during the
riots and then have like 150 people run
in that video where the guys like
shooting at the window to try and break
into like a Dolce store or whatever it's
called I mean it's it's Decay uh what
about uh what is happening in
Philadelphia why is every other video
every video I see of something awful
like some type of execution or something
like robbery in broad daylight yesterday
morning top of my Twitter feed with some
Mom some ring doorbell camera some mom
she's getting her kids ready she's like
is Suburban mom getting her kids into
the minivan and some dude carjacks or
with their kids and he had like a
handgun with a 50 round drum in it or
something yo some ridiculous weapon I
that as a parent I got two little girls
like as a parent that is uh that is like
uh it's hard to think of something worse
than that actually someone like grabbing
my car keys and running away with my
kids dude we used to play at the park
around the corner from my house growing
up this is like a 1980s 19 early 90s and
we just go there'd be like four kids age
nine to eleven playing on the swing set
no parents I was just thinking a couple
nights ago how how in the modern day to
consider letting your kids go off for
hours a time like well first of all I
can't constantly be watching the kids 24
7. so yeah they're gonna be off on their
own but like and they yeah there's a
fence around the backyard but like can
they go to the park I don't know I was
in a suburb but even today like what
state Ohio Cuyahoga Falls Ohio no it's
getting crazy now there's a bunch of
story there was one story I read about
uh a mom had Child Protective Services
called on her because her kid was
playing in the front yard by himself and
it was like seven years old when I was
seven I was gone I was I was like come
back when the street lights come on I
can handle like woke trash like
Protective Service crap but but it's the
crime it's that that someone would get
carjacked in their driveway is that
where the mom was in her driveway
driveway you can see the ring doorbell
cameras you know I'm not I don't have it
in front of me are they legally allowed
to carry in in that area in Philadelphia
no way that's freaking crazy no way
that's like that's like a Revolt waiting
to happen this is why Dr Oz I mean like
might actually might actually win thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there